[Music]
at this point
just call her addison ray kardashian i
love it
the 19 year old social media star teamed
up with the kardashians on tick tock
again and it's probably safe to say
she's officially part of the crew i'm a
fan girl like for sure
over the weekend addison who is the
second most followed star on the social
media platform with over 50 million
followers shared this clip featuring a
swarm of members from the famous fans
don't blink or you might miss kourtney
kardashian scott disick
their kids penelope and mason kim and
kanye's daughter north
and a few other pals
[Music]
that's the teen rocking some serious
choreo with scott disick
well at least trying to and
that's scott and court's eight-year-old
daughter penelope straight up strolling
through the shot
i'm like watching the kardashians and
i'm like oh my gosh i wonder what that'd
be like to experience that
i get it and um it is crazy that i'm in
that position now
as for addison and court they seem to be
the newest besties in hollywood
the two were spotted getting dinner
together at nobu
in malibu on friday night the same
restaurant they went to together
earlier that week so yeah apparently
they're regulars
of course this isn't the first time
court and addison have teamed up
in june the duo served up some major
keeping up with the kardashians
nostalgia
i just cry myself to sleep every night
reenacting
that scene from the hit reality show i
mean i feel
fine i just cry myself to sleep every
night yeah that's totally normal
and remember this mother-daughter moment
between kris jenner and khloe kardashian
you know we're thong i mean not not in
public
oh wow you are conservative
yeah they tic-tocked the hell out of
that one too
you already have this well i can't wear
it because do you see the back it's the
thong
what do you think i am you don't wear a
thong i mean not
not in public oh wow you are
conservative
the new besties also did some choreo in
the closet
and addison even linked up with court's
ten-year-old son mason
who showed off some pretty impressive
moves
but before all that court invited the
tick tock star to collab on a push video
where addison broke down her signature
booty workout
i start feeling it so much on the fire
hydrants like my
side butt is just burning
good thing i did not do butt yesterday
when e.t caught up with addison in
february
court's little sister kendall had just
started following the teen on tick tock
and addison was shook kendall jenner
just recently joined tick tock
yeah like yesterday she followed me
that's so cool
i don't it's so cool i don't know i was
like what the heck
and when et spoke with addison's rumored
beau bryce hall
he gave his two cents on addison and
court's newfound friendship
what do you think of her videos with
kourtney kardashian when the heck did
she start hanging out with the
kardashians i right i mean you guys
really are that
big though like the kardashians are
trying i'm not hanging out with the
kardashians
i'm not that you haven't gotten invited
yet
yeah no i'm i'm waiting for hey kylie
what's up i'm waiting for a party invite
[Music]